en otros vídeos hemos hablado sobre la
idea de la forma estándar de una
ecuación lineal y el objetivo de este
vídeo es aclarar y resolver algunas
diferencias que pueden ver en diferentes
clases sobre lo que es la forma estándar
todos están de acuerdo en que la forma
estándar es generalmente una ecuación
lineal donde tienes un número x x más un
número x que y eso es igual a algún
número de modo que la forma estándar
incluye cosas como 3 x + 4 y es igual a
10 o 2 x + 5 y es igual a menos 10 todos
estarían de acuerdo en que esto está en
forma estándar y todos estarían de
acuerdo en que lo siguiente no es la
forma estándar si escribiera 3x es igual
a menos cuatro y más diez aunque éstas
son ecuaciones equivalentes esta no está
en la forma estándar del mismo modo si
escribo que ya es igual a tres
x 7 eso tampoco está en la forma
estándar ahora algunas personas pueden
estar en desacuerdo si vieran algo así
como 6 x + 8 y es igual a 20 por qué
algunas personas argumentan que esto no
es la forma estándar bueno algunas
personas dirán que en la forma estándar
los coeficientes de xy y de nuestro
término constante es decir abc no pueden
compartir ningún factor común aquí el 6
el 8 y el 20 son divisibles entre 2 por
lo que algunas personas dirían que esto
no es una forma estándar y para hacerlo
en forma estándar dividirían todos estos
entre 2 y si lo hiciera no tendrían esta
ecuación que tenemos aquí ahora esto es
útil porque entonces tienes una ecuación
única pero en khan academy no lo
restringimos de esa manera y esa también
es una forma de pensar muy popular sólo
queremos que pienses de esta forma a x +
vélez es igual a c cuando hagas
ejercicio se encaran academy no vamos a
comprobar si estos coeficientes
y tienen un factor común por lo tanto
para los propósitos de que me academy
esto se considera como la forma estándar
aunque no se sorprendan si se encuentran
con algunas personas que dicen que no lo
es y que prefieren eliminar cualquier
factor común ahora otro ejemplo sería
algo como menos 3 x menos 4 y es igual a
menos 10
algunas personas dirían que esta no es
una forma estándar porque quieren que
este primer coeficiente que tenemos aquí
la a sea mayor que 0 mientras que aquí
es menor que cero para nuestros
propósitos en khan academy consideramos
que esto es la forma estándar pero solo
te lo hago saber porque algunas personas
podrían considerar que no lo es porque
este coeficiente principal no es mayor
que cero
otro ejemplo con el que algunas personas
podrían estar en desacuerdo sería 1.25 x
+ 5.50 y es igual a 10.5 la razón por la
que algunas personas podrían no
considerar esto como la forma estándar
es que a veces no son enteros
algunas personas dirían que en la forma
estándar habéis de vencer enteros y
podrían multiplicar ambos lados de la
ecuación por algún valor para que
tuvieran números enteros en abc pero
para los propósitos de khan academy
consideramos que esto está escrito en la
forma estándar pensamos que esto es
importante no solo poder tener números
que no son enteros en abc sino también
poder tener una negativa como este 3 que
es nuestra a y también poder tener
coeficientes abc que tengan factores
compartidos creemos que todo eso es
importante porque a veces la ecuación en
sí misma tiene un significado cuando se
escribe de esa manera veremos que cuando
hacemos algunos problemas verbales
cuando entramos en la vida real y
tratamos de construir ecuaciones con
base en la información de la ecuación es
más fácil de entender si la mantenemos
en esa forma por lo tanto para los
propósitos de khan academy esta es una
forma estándar
pero es bueno que en sus vidas
matemáticas tengan en cuenta que algunas
personas quieren ver la restricción de
un factor común entre abc que hace a
mayor que 0 y que a b y c sean todos
enteros
khan academy no te obliga a eso